apparently so what this company thought
I was charming and not like a total
loser
so datasize is a pretty specialist field
but I kind of fell into it by accident I
had no intentions of being a data
scientist I moved to LA about a year and
six months ago
we have no job no place to stay none of
that and I was just kind of like in
turning around the City of LA I had my
own small YouTube channel and I was a
big BuzzFeed fair girl I watched like
all the videos I liked had all my
favorites I was in my final week of
college doing finals and I flipped out
one night and I was like well I need to
get a damn good job I'm a very big
soccer fan and I wasn't a betting pool
with a bunch of my friends and I was
doing really well in it so I was like
you know what I bet I could write an
algorithm that does all this betting for
me on scale and then I could sit back
and just rake in the cash
I wouldn't started teaching myself data
science using free online courses for
the sole purpose of writing a betting
algorithm and getting rich off of it
when I found out that they were hiring a
friend of mine who had went through the
internship here said oh you'd be perfect
for this I'll recommend you a one night
I went out and I got I'm extremely
extremely intoxicated but got back home
at about like 3:00 in the morning and my
drunk brain convinced me that I should
look for jobs apart for like seven jobs
with this company and then after that I
graduated I lived my life and the night
of my birthday actually I got an email
from BuzzFeed to do a video interview so
here's the thing I am I was intoxicated
because I've been drinking since like
9:00 a.m. and then I saw that any of you
and I was like like I actually need to
like look appropriate and look nice and
not look like I've been having like five
tequila shots I was like you know
BuzzFeed's a viral company they like
internet things and trends on the
internet and so I tweeted if this tweet
gets a thousand retweets the BuzzFeed
has to hire me because that's how the
internet works I got called in for my
interview on the way I got very nervous
so I kept checking my phone to make sure
I was going the right way
and one of the times was checking my
phone don't check your phone while
driving I didn't notice the person in
front of me stopped moving and rolled
right into him I wasn't going superfast
but it definitely hit the car in front
of me and I was like oh this catches on
this will be like the most epic BuzzFeed
like article it didn't catch on it got
nowhere near thousand retweets I don't
even know if anyone had BuzzFeed ever
saw it it just kind of like was a really
sad thing and I was like I kind of
wanted to delete the tweet just cuz I
was like oh this is embarrassing for me
but I put this out there and got nowhere
near where I wanted don't think now it's
just a sad BuzzFeed article immediately
I called the person I was meeting here
at BuzzFeed for better view of a like I
might be late I just hit a car and I
really caught it was starting to cry and
this was percent of the other line I was
like are you okay don't worry about it
we can like adjust your tablet like no
no I think I'll figure it out I did this
video interview and I looked at the
camera I was like honey my name is Joey
it's something really fun loving I don't
even remember much of what it said it
was mostly like what's your favorite
about speed video and I couldn't think
of crap so like oh I look really loved
the dry guys when that guy gets out of
the car and we have a discussion and he
clearly like just doesn't want to deal
with me so we kind of like leaves never
heard from this guy again so I'm still
sorry sir and I like get to BuzzFeed I'm
still on time I'm five minutes early and
they're like do you need a moment I'm
like no no I got this like you're still
shaking finally enough nobody from the
from BuzzFeed actually got back to me
when I put on the website and so I went
online and I went on Twitter and I'm
LinkedIn and every recruiter I found
that was for BuzzFeed anybody that said
anything about the boats detect him I
just started messaging him directly on
after two months and I think seven or
eight stages of interviews I eventually
got hired to be the first data scientist
and BuzzFeed LA's operations while I was
out here interning I ended up being an
extra in a BuzzFeed video where I met
another production coordinator here and
we ended up getting coffee and then I
just kind of told some my experiences
and then I showed him the tweet he
laughed at it and he was like yeah no
that's that's not gonna work but he told
me to apply for the position I applied
and interviewed and the rest is history
I'm at the end of
I was like Oh what are you looking for
in an employee here and they said oh you
know someone here's kind of goes with
the flow and I was like well if you want
someone that goes with the flow
I got it an accident on the way here and
still made it to my interview on time if
they were like and then like a couple
days later I was asked to come to
California for the big interview and
they really liked me and it's all
because I got drunk one night on my
birthday overall I would say the
funniest part of all this is you know me
lining this really big career jump as a
result of gambling drinking fangirl
turned employee this cinderella story if
you put it out there I mean whatever
your goal is whatever your dreams are no
matter how like ridiculous they may seem
at the time it's really weird that in
some way I think putting it out there
makes it more real so I'll put it out
there universe might give it to you
[Music]